Oh little girls start pageants when
they're like two and then if they're the
best at it they get to become Miss
Universe I don't know anything you know
you come out dressed up looking good and
then they hit you with the hard-hitting
questions where's the best swimsuits
right is that what it is would you ever
date someone your family hated didn't I
ask you that right I feel like this is a
trick one because you know some people
who like I want an independent lady
who's gonna be like I don't care if I
love them I love them but then you know
people watching like now I need somebody
who's gonna be in tune with their family
either way that's a trick question
lock the boat I've moved out of the
house got my own car I got my own job I
think that will go over well I'm not
answering the question I know I'm still
reading time but the answer is yes I
could because I have my own experience
as I define my own life just like every
woman in the world should be able to
nailed it
if you were pregnant could you still
compete in this beauty pageant these are
terrible how about you answer me this
you take a turn turn the table back turn
the table back that's a real saying I
just made it up right now and ask
yourself does this make sense are you
trying to make me a robot just so I can
be beautiful for you for the rest of
your life and then turn the table
background on me and I'm gonna say no
yeah women can have a family and a
career look at cardi B yo cardi B was
pregnant and she did a whole tour okay
okay
I can't do that what is something silly
that makes you self-conscious
you know silly questions like this what
are we determining with this question
like what what happened where's the
question I've got a whole book of
questions on how to solve the economic
crisis and you ask me questions like
this like where's the jump talking about
section for my parents that's probably
one of the bad ones
right I mean probably the answer that
some people went with was probably just
like famine what is one thing you change
about your body I'll get a six-pack this
one question is the one chance to like
show some like elocution and some poise
and some ability to like talk and think
through ideas and the thing that we've
chosen to ask them is about their
physical body the thing that we're
judging them on everything else anyways
you know I'd like to have a third arm oh
you thought I was gonna say something
sexy
ha ha joke's on you I'm all about
utility if women took a class from men
what would they teach them cutting
people off to say what I need to say Oh
cuz I wasted so much time not even
understanding the question how did like
man spread not a gut thing let's be a
hundred percent real a contest about
like beautiful women come on that that's
built for who by who I won right that's
right